cuáles son las implicaciones de que una
nueva variante esté en esta lista de la
organización mundial de la salud
buenas noches significa que esta
variante tiene el potencial
para generar mayor transmisibilidad
bloquear la efectiva de las lunas y
probablemente podría también tener algún
apoyo potencial para aumentar la
agresividad o la letalidad en este caso
para específicamente para la variante
view se se prende la alarma porque
tienen mutaciones que hacen que la hacen
especial justamente para potencialmente
aumentar esa transmisión y bloquear el
efecto poco
preparados en anticuerpos
profesor este tipo de decisiones de la
oms ya no terminan estigmatizando el
país de origen de las variantes en este
caso colombia
es una de las que se ha tenido con el
loris cuando se mira el origen de la de
una variante pero definitivamente el
hecho de que se haya cambiado justamente
la nomenclatura llamarlas pobre en este
caso alfabeto griego
justamente tratando de evitar esa
estigmatización y adicionalmente porque
no es injusta la estigmatización dado
que es lo que ocurre es que un país la
identifica no significa que esté en ese
país solamente sino que justamente
dentro del portal hacia genómica que se
puede detectar las variantes del virus
del tipo de virus que circulan en un
determinado país se encuentra y se
encuentra y esto hace que muchas veces
como vimos al comienzo con el caso de
las variantes alfa beta o gamma pues
puede generar para mí es importante
tener en cuenta como usted lo comentaba
que la variante se originó no se originó
perdón en que se identificó primero pero
está circulando en múltiples países de
algodón del mundo
y una pregunta que le interesa a alguna
parte de la audiencia con las vacunas
que ya se están aplicando en el mundo
tenemos ya una protección frente a estas
variantes que van surgiendo
esta dificultad de saber justamente si
la esterilidad del trabajo
cada vez que aparece una variante puede
ocurrir es el temor que las vacunas
técnicas de la efectividad en este
momento es claro que la par la variante
yum podría ser afectada por las vacunas
como potencialmente perder algo en la
efectividad no lo sabemos
y seguir investigando ahora que está
reculando en varios países evaluar qué
tanto afecta a esa efectividad lo buena
noticia es que hasta ahora la mayoría de
variantes que se han presentado no han
logrado algo mejor
se ha mantenido la vacuna su efectiva
contra ellas han perdido 10 o 15 por
ciento de su efectividad pero siguen
teniendo un porcentaje muy alto que hace
que la estrategia vacunación sigue
siendo la estrategia ganadora para la
protección